[Musique]
ils sont ici ils sont là les
influenceurs ans par les matches y
adapte à la conquête de l'amérique du
nord
lemouchi c'est un produit qui est mignon
qui est bon et qui va aller chercher en
fait une nouvelle clientèle et répondent
aux nouveaux besoins des clients qui
veulent manger plus des produits
ethniques en fait goûter des choses
différents et voyager dans l'assiette
petite boule de pâte de riz d'environ 35
grammes le mochi qui fait tourner les
têtes ces jours ci contient en son
centre de la crème glacée natrel et le
choix du président offrent leurs gammes
en épicerie en temps normal chez cool
est simple on peut choisir à l'unité
mais en cette période de pandémie
on vend en boutique et en ligne des
plateaux préemballés offert en une
dizaine de saveur ça se mange vraiment
avec les doigts son cornet sont cuillère
sans rien qu'est ce qui caractérise le
bon mot chine selon vous pour moi c'est
la pâte de riz en fait la texture le
goût et surtout la pâte de riz la pâte
de riz c'est ça va être un petit peu
élastique est assez épaisse en fait le
moins bon moshi parfois la crème glacée
va se confondre avec la pâte de riz
alors dans le bon mot chien on sent
vraiment les deux textures en fait entre
la pâte de riz et la crème glacée
les matchs se décline aussi farsi par
exemple de sésame de chocolat ou encore
de fèves rouges une tradition japon
depuis plus de 2000 ans le mochi a une
symbolique religieuse et sert
d'offrandes au nouvel an on dit que ces
mortiers c'est quelque chose de sacré
ont décollé il est à la du qui vit dans
l'âme aussi séduit c'était important
pour asia tic comme pratt rispal donc
pour l'avancée de vie c'est vraiment
important pour la vie c'est pour ça on
dit qu il y à la 12 lits et moti c1
signification de toutes la wii dame
chance le mochi traditionnelle est à la
base une bougie formée avec une patte de
bicol cette pâte et façonné en martelant
de manière spectaculaire le riz collant
cuit jusqu'à l'obtention de la texture
des yeux mais aujourd'hui un appareil
permet à 40 minutes d'obtenir un bon
résultat
monti mochis motti monty mon tir primé
mazet d'iphone comme anti une boule de
pâte de fèves rouges sucré au centre la
pâte hazuki
scénic scénic scénic ou vraie celle ci
dessous ouais ouais c'est bon oui rennie
pas fait vous mangez sa matière match
comme ça oui oui oui oui
beau contraste avec la barre de fer la
partie est encore chaude offre une autre
variante et le qui n'a comme mochis un
mois çi nature enrobé de poudre de fèves
de soya rôti nous
[Musique]
sur une première dette je dirais non
mais ça coûte un peu l'arachide l'afev
de soyaux rôti chez les enfants et marne
à ay sauver mon pti ils sont venus dire
ok isobe il sourit sa venue au bord de
la mer je vais tromper dans le soya et
sur le hockey est simplement vous allez
pas emballé avec
désert
[Musique]
finalement le chef prépare halle aux
chiroux qu'au mois çi il s'agit d'un
bouillon de fèves rouges sucré et de
mortiers nature mises en garde ici ne
prenez pas trop grosse bouchée pour
éviter de vous étouffer à du mensuel ici
normalement les gens pensent quelque
chose de beau c'est jesse le goût au
japon toujours on va considérer trois
choses le groupe
ça va alomar et chose de plus important
c'est la texture texture menti ils ont
la texture du goût sucré ou salé chaud
ou glacés les mochis une gâterie
japonaise à découvrir
[Musique]